but first i want to lay out for you my
thoughts on the president's recovery
the media's reaction and what it all
means for the election
let's start with the human side it was
great to see the president's video
tonight but the one
i really appreciated was last night
after all the media coverage the wild
and hysterical speculation it was such a
relief
to see the president's message and there
was one part that really showed he's
back in business
melania is really handling it
very nicely as you've probably read
she's slightly younger than me just a
little tiny bit
yup he's making jokes definitely a good
sign
but it's all a sign of something deeper
too the president's recovery is a
powerful symbol of america's recovery
yes he got the virus because he was out
there fighting for the future of the
country not
hiding in a basement he's been saying
for months we need to be open not
closed that we've got to beat the virus
not surrender to it
of course that has risks but that's the
american way
to take risks so you get a bigger reward
and we're seeing
that now with a recovery that is faster
than europe
stronger than anyone was predicting
president trump is a living symbol
of that positive can-do spirit people
are free to disagree with it
but it's a clear contrast with biden it
gives voters a clear
choice another contrast the president
has been fighting for years
for better health care through
innovation he is the right to try
president he wanted americans to have
the chance to try
life-saving new treatments and he swept
away the bureaucracy that stood in the
way
you saw natalie harp at the republican
convention and here on this show
saying she owes her life to that now
president trump himself
putting his own health his life frankly
where his policy has been
taking innovative treatments like
convalescent plasma and severe
regeneron and showing that they work
let's be clear the only reason these
treatments are available today is
because president trump
pushed for them against the bureaucracy
and the status quo thinking of the swamp
he wants them available to every
american that's why he's battling the
fda bureaucrats over all this
he is a living symbol of why he's right
and right to fight
but for the democrats and the
trump-hating establishment media
the president is now a symbol of a
different kind
within minutes of him announcing his
positive test result they could barely
contain their smug
satisfaction in large part
uh it's his own dereliction is
partly to blame for this certainly his
recklessness
uh has contributed to this horrible
situation
he has time and again denied the
seriousness of the pandemic suggested
that the nation was rounding the corner
and in its last legs with this
battling this virus fly in the face of
science and been wrong
over and over and now of course he has
contracted it
and the questions are what comes next
the next day did you see how they all
went through the motions of decency
before getting to what they
really wanted to do attacked trump and
glory in his
misfortune this is tragic it's very sad
but it also is something that that again
going into crowds uh unmasked and all
the rest
was sort of a brazen invitation for
something like this to happen
her message was no different to the
chinese regimes they said
the president and the first lady paid
the price for playing down the virus
nice allies you've got there nancy the
democrats of course
cynically tried to exploit the situation
for partisan ends
biden suddenly decided he needed to wear
a mask while he was speaking
and these are the people who say we
shouldn't politicize mask wearing
schumer was straight out the gate trying
to use this to stop amy coney barrett's
confirmation
and most ludicrously of all deranged
senator chris murphy
utterly embarrassed himself with some
preposterous putin plot
but none of that none of it is as bad as
what we've seen from the media these
last few days
their whole reaction has been one giant
i told you so
we were right all along they smuggly
crow
nothing captured that more than this
today from biden aid masquerading as a
journalist
jake tapper to mr president
you have become a symbol of your own
failures
failures of recklessness ignorance
arrogance
the same failures you have been
inflicting on the rest of us
we've heard a lot about herd immunity
what we're seeing now on cnn and msnbc
and the new york times and washington
post and all the rest of the
establishment
propagandists is herd stupidity
their central claim is that trump didn't
follow the science
reasonable intelligent thinking people
talk about science it's unthinking
ideologues
who talk about the science tapper and
todd and
wallace and maddow and all the others
they claim that everything to do with
the virus is cut and tried
that is misinformation scientists are
learning new
things all the time and scientists
themselves disagree
originally scientists thought the virus
was carried by droplets droplets fall
under their own weight no further than a
few feet away
that was the basis for the six feet
social distancing rule
but now scientists say the virus travels
through the air in what they call
aerosols
they can travel up to 30 feet and hang
around for hours
so the most useful thing right now might
be to encourage the widespread use of
air filtration systems
known as hepa filters that block virus
transmission
scientific studies support the use of
n95 masks
as a protection against the virus but
many scientific studies show that cloth
masks don't stop virus particles the
world health organization
like dr fauci and the cdc as we know
originally told us not to wear masks
but even when they changed their mind
they didn't actually pretend that masks
stopped the virus
the who said mars should be three layer
and that even with those
quote the use of a mask alone is
insufficient to provide an adequate
level of protection
or source control and listen to the
reasons they gave
for wearing masks reducing
stigmatization
making people feel included most of the
reasons weren't
even medical in any case the data
doesn't even support what the media are
saying
if you listen to them the last few days
president trump has practically been
running around the country ripping
people's marks off their faces
and we're the most maskless place on
earth in fact we're relatively high
on mask wearing and much higher than
some countries with much lower infection
rates
it's the same ideological pseudoscience
with shutdowns
anyone who dares suggests opening things
up is pretty much branded a murderer
but more and more evidence is
accumulating that the shutdowns
did more harm than good with little
effect on the virus
but massive health social and economic
costs
establishment media won't even allow
this to be said
they go on and on about contact tracing
but the latest research
suggests that the whole premise of the
current contact tracing approach is
flawed
as i've said here before an old playbook
for a different disease
we're now learning that the most
significant factor in spreading the
virus
could be clusters most people who have
the virus don't infect anyone
tracing their contacts is a waste of
time and resources
jake tapper accused president trump of
arrogance and ignorance
but when he spouts off about the science
he's the one displaying ignorance
i want to read to you the words of an
actual scientist
an infectious disease professor who is
on the uk equivalent of the coronavirus
task force
quote both the virus and the ways of
tackling it
cause harm and need to be balanced while
scientists can ensure that any
strategies are underpinned
by the best evidence in research they
should have
no greater say in them than economists
ethicists historians
and the wider public just as in society
at large
there are some scientists who think the
cure is worse than the disease
this is now a central choice in the
election policy should be
informed by scientists not run by
scientists
president trump listens to the
scientists and then
leads joe biden is led by them he told
us that i'll shut it down he said
all the pundits are saying that this
episode is a disaster for trump
because it will focus attention on
coronavirus instead of the economy
well that could just be another example
of herd
stupidity if the president's recovery
continues
if he shows a new more positive and more
human side as he has been doing this
weekend
and leaves the attacks on biden to his
surrogates it will focus attention on
what
everyone wants to see recovery
president trump's recovery achieved in
no small part because of the actions he
took
to get new treatments available as a
living symbol of
america's recovery a massive contrast
with the weak defeatism of joe biden and
his threat
of another shutdown beating the virus
bringing back the economy recovery with
trump
or relapse with biden